[Orientalische Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute möchte ich einmal ein Experiment starten,
und zwar gibt es heute eine Künefe-Roll.
Künefe ist kein türkisches Dessert,
aber ein Dessert der orientalischen Küche, sage ich einmal.
Wenn ich jetzt sage, es ist ein türkisches Dessert,
kommen die Araber und sagen: „Nein, das ist gehört uns!“
Dann kommen die Libanesen und sagen: „Nein, das gehört uns!“
Künefe oder Künafa ist ein Dessert,
was es in vielen Ländern dieser Welt gibt
und es gibt Abwandlungen davon.
Ich habe auch schon ein Rezept davon auf meinem Kanal.
Und zwar besteht es aus Teigfäden, nämlich diesen Engelshaaren.
Es ist ein Dessert, wo auch Käse mitgebacken wird
und dann noch warm aus dem Ofen mit kaltem Sirup übergossen wird
- sehr, sehr lecker!
Es klingt ein bisschen außergewöhnlich, aber es ist sehr lecker.
Davon inspiriert möchte ich heute eine Biskuit-Rolle machen,
das Ganze also ein bisschen europäischer machen
und vor allem ein bisschen leichter.
Ich liebe Künefe,
aber ich glaube, diese Abwandlung davon wird schon recht cool.
Zuerst werde ich den Sirup herstellen und dann die Biskuit-Rolle
und später dann die Füllung.
Normalerweise sollte dieses Gericht gar nicht so lange dauern.
Also könnt ihr auch sehr gut vorbereiten
und dann im Kühlschrank lagern.
Für den Sirup nehme ich
100 g Wasser, 150 g Zucker und etwas Limettensaft
und für die Biskuit-Rolle 60 g Butter, 200 g Teigfäden
- das ist Engelshaar, also Kadayıf –,
4 Eier, 100 g Zucker, eine Prise Salz, 100 g Mehl,
bei Bedarf etwas Backpulver – etwa 1/2 TL –und Kardamom.
Ich glaube, Kardamomfrüchte passen da ganz gut dazu.
Ich hatte die, glaube ich, auf meinem Kanal nicht oder selten benutzt,
weil es auch einfach ein tolles Gewürz z. B. der indischen Küche ist
und es passt wirklich zu vielen Dingen.
In der arabischen Küche wird es auch oft im Kaffee
oder auch beim Tee direkt mitgekocht – also wirklich super lecker!
Wir probieren es einfach.
Für den Sirup gebt ihr jetzt einfach
das Wasser mit dem Zucker in einen Topf.
Dann aufkochen lassen.
[Musik]
In der Zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt hier auch schon einmal
die Butter schmelzen – bei niedriger Stufe
und schon einmal mein Blech vorbereiten.
Ich benutze jetzt hier einfach eine Backfolie.
Ihr könnt auch Backpapier nehmen
und einen Backrahmen, ein normales Backblech geht aber auch.
Bei so einem Backrahmen habt ihr einfach den Vorteil,
dass er wirklich schön rechteckig ist.
Gerade bei einer Biskuit-Rolle finde ich das wichtig,
damit ihr nicht die abgerundeten Ecken habt,
die ihr dann wegschneiden müsst,
könnt ihr praktisch die Biskuitrolle komplett verwerten.
[Musik]
Dann kann ich die Butter hier unten direkt aufstreichen.
Das bewirkt dann auch gleich, dass die Teigfäden etwas Farbe bekommen
und natürlich auch dieser butterigen Geschmack.
Bei einem traditionellen Künefe
werden nämlich die Teigfäden auch mit Butter ummantelt
und dann werden die auch richtig schön knusprig.
Also einmal hier unten aufstreichen.
Der Sirup darf gern ein bisschen einkochen.
Dann kommen hier die Teigfäden hinein, am besten längs.
Ruhig so ein bisschen auseinanderzupfen.
[Musik]
Wie so ein schöner Teppich.
Dann die restliche Butter noch draufstreichen.
[Musik]
Das darf dann schon einmal in den Backofen,
und zwar in die untere Einschubleiste,
denn ich möchte, dass die Unterseite schön gebräunt wird.
[Musik und Uhr]
Hier bei der Limette nehme ich jetzt einfach die Schale ab.
Da achtet ihr einfach darauf, dass die Schale verzehrbar ist.
Das steht oft mit dabei, dass sie unbedenklich ist.
Die benutze ich nämlich später für die Creme.
Jetzt hier für den Sirup brauche ich ein bisschen Säure,
entweder Zitronen- oder Limettensaft,
damit der nicht so kristallin wird
– dass er einfach schön flüssig bleibt.
Ein bisschen etwas könnt ihr gern mit hineingeben
und dann die Limette halbieren.
Einfach ein bisschen Saft mit dazugeben
und kurz noch einmal weiterkochen.
Dann sollte er jetzt schon ein bisschen dickflüssiger sein.
Wenn ihr den hinunterfließen lasst, dann fließt er wie an einem Faden,
also nicht so abgehackt, sondern wie an einem Faden.
Der sieht schon gut aus.
Dann fülle ich ihn um und lasse ihn abkühlen.
Der sollte nämlich kalt sein,
wenn die Biskuit-Rolle gleich fertig ist.
Dann hole ich kurz meine Küchenmaschine
und kann anfangen, den Teig zu verrühren.
[Musik]
Bei mir hat es jetzt 8 Minuten lang im Backofen geröstet.
Also ihr schaut einfach: Wenn es so leicht braun wird,
dann ist es perfekt, denn es kommt ja noch einmal in den Backofen
und wird noch einmal gebacken.
Deswegen nicht zu dunkel werden lassen.
Jetzt kann ich hier direkt schon die Eier verrühren.
Die sollten schön zimmerwarm sein.
Salz und Zucker.
[Lacht] Ich habe Salz daneben geschüttet.
Ich sammle es wieder auf.
Ich habe heute kein Vanilleextrakt.
Das geht nicht.
JOSH: Machst du da Tonka rein?
SALLY: Ein bisschen Vanille.
Ich glaube, Tonka würde ich jetzt nicht nehmen,
weil ich schon Kardamom und Limetten habe.
Ich glaube, Tonka wäre dann too much.
Ich glaube, entweder Tonka oder Kardamom.
JOSH: Okay.
SALLY: Ja. Und kein Kiwi, Josh!
[Beide lachen]
Das war so ein Insider – egal.
Jetzt die Masse schön schaumig aufschlagen lassen,
so etwa 5-10 Minuten.
Ihr könnt die Masse auch kürzer aufschlagen
und dann Backpulver benutzen.
Ich bevorzuge es allerdings bei Biskuit-Teigen,
bei Biskuit-Massen einfach das Backpulver wegzulassen
und schön luftig schlagen,
denn dadurch kommt auch das Volumen zustande.
Aber ihr könnt beides machen – das bleibt euch überlassen.
[Küchenmaschine, Uhr und Musik]
So sollte die Zuckermasse jetzt aussehen – schön dickcremig.
Jetzt könnt ihr hier das Mehl mit dem Backpulver,
wenn ihr möchtet, einfach dazu sieben.
[Musik]
Ich habe hier jetzt noch gemahlenen Kardamom gefunden.
Den könnt ihr nehmen.
Oder auch Kardamom-Kapseln einfach zerkleinern
- mit dem Mörser oder mit dem Mixer.
Jetzt die Zutaten unterheben.
Wenn ihr wollt, gern noch eine Prise Limettenschale
- nicht zu viel, denn ich will,
dass die Creme den Limettengeschmack bekommt.
Viele heben das Mehl immer mit dem Teigschaber unter.
So wird es auch immer beigebracht,
aber ich finde,
mit dem Schneebesen hat man direkt viel weniger Umdrehungen
und hat das Mehl viel schneller eingearbeitet.
Wenn man da ganz vorsichtig ist,
dann ist es, finde ich zumindest, besser
- also könnt ihr gern einmal ausprobieren.
Jetzt ist das Blech auch nicht mehr heiß.
Da kann die Masse jetzt draufgestrichen werden.
Der Ofen ist immer noch heiß – 210°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
Dann sollte die Biskuit-Platte auch sofort
im heißen Ofen gebacken werden.
Auch immer nur kurz und deswegen auch so eine hohe Temperatur,
damit sie nicht austrocknet, denn wenn ihr sie zu lange backt,
dann wird sie trocken und brüchig.
Wenn ihr sie heiß und kurz backt,
ist sie innen schön saftig und reißt dann auch beim Aufrollen nicht.
Jetzt einfach schön verstreichen.
[Musik]
Dann kann jetzt die Platte direkt gebacken werden.
[Musik und Uhr]
Dann könnt ihr jetzt nach dem Backen
die Biskuit-Platte direkt herauslösen.
[Musik]
Dann gebe ich da ein sauberes Geschirrtuch darauf.
Nicht vergessen: Das Blech ist noch heiß.
Ui. [Lacht]
Bisschen mehr Farbe hätte es kriegen dürfen, muss ich sagen,
aber es ist okay.
Da gebe ich jetzt den Sirup darauf – der ist schön abgekühlt.
[Musik]
Erst einmal abkühlen lassen.
Sobald es kalt ist
– also ich decke es jetzt noch mit einem weiteren Geschirrtuch ab,
damit es einfach nicht austrocknet –
Sobald es kalt ist, kann ich mich schon um die Füllung kümmern.
Es geht jetzt auch relativ schnell.
Also eigentlich kann ich mich jetzt schon um die Füllung kümmern.
[Musik]
Bei der Creme habe ich mich
für eine Mascarpone-Sahnecreme entschieden.
Ihr könnt aber auch Frischkäse, Quark oder Sahnejoghurt verwenden.
Sahnejoghurt solltet ihr aber vorher ein bisschen abhängen,
dass die Flüssigkeit abtropft.
Ich habe jetzt hier 500 g Mascarpone, meine Limetten,
ich brauche etwas Puderzucker – das sind 80 g -,
400 g Sahne und etwas San-apart.
Ich mache das jetzt zuerst so,
dass ich noch ein bisschen Limettenabrieb brauche
- nicht Zitronen, sondern Limetten.
Wie gesagt, überall ist die Schale bei den Limetten verzehrbar.
Die restlichen, die ich habe
– ich brauche jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht alle -,
kann ich trotzdem abreiben und die Limettenschale – den Abrieb –
einfach einfrieren.
Dann habe ich das auch immer auf Vorrat.
Dann lohnt es sich auch, dass man Bio und unbehandelt kauft,
denn man kann ja wirklich die komplette Zitrusfrucht verwerten.
Ich sage es immer wieder, aber manche wissen es nicht:
Sobald ich dann die Limette oder die Zitrone ausgepresst habt,
könnt ihr sie auch als Spülmaschinen-Deo benutzen.
Einfach mit in die Spülmaschine legen – für 1-2 Spülgänge
und dann wegschmeißen
und dann habt ihr immer einen schönen frischen Duft.
[Musik]
Dann kann ich es jetzt hier direkt in die Rührschüssel geben.
Ich muss sagen, Limetten sind schon etwas Feines.
Ich finde sie echt viel aromatischer als Zitronen – ist schon so.
Der Mascarpone dazu.
Oh, ich habe keinen Teigschaber, aber jetzt.
Dann den Puderzucker hinein und kurz verrühren.
[Handrührgerät]
Mascarpone nicht zu lange rühren,
sondern wirklich nur so lange, bis er cremig ist.
In der Zeit kann ich den Limettensaft auspressen.
[Musik]
Jetzt den Limettensaft dazugeben.
Dann kommt langsam die Sahne dazu.
Dann könnt ihr die Creme mit San-apart steifschlagen.
[Musik]
Jetzt werde ich die Platte einmal stürzen,
denn ich möchte ja die Künefe,
also die Kadayıf – das Engelshaar – außen haben.
So viele Namen.
Ich muss auch sagen, zu der Rolle war ich inspiriert,
weil ich ein Bild von Künefe Rolls gesehen habe.
Sarah ich und waren beide so: „Boah!“
Okay, Josh auch!
„Das müssen wir machen. Das müssen wir probieren.“
Vielleicht mache ich noch Künefe Rolls.
Ich habe noch genug Engelshaar, und Mozzarella.
Vielleicht machen wir das noch kurz als Mini-Rezept im Rezept.
Okay, jetzt hier die Creme auf die Biskuit-Platte verstreichen.
Ich nehme dann immer gern eine Teigkarte.
Die könnt ihr nämlich hier an den Rand legen
und praktisch die Creme bis zum Rand schön streichen,
ohne dass ihr darüber hinaus streicht,
ohne dass die Creme dann hinaus quillt.
Hier vorn einen kleinen Rand zum Einrollen lassen.
[Musik]
Ich bin echt der Alptraum aller Kinder, gell? [Lacht]
Ich schabe die Sachen so lange aus,
bis nichts mehr zum Abschlecken bleibt.
Aber ich muss sagen, wenn die Kinder da sind,
dann mache ich noch einmal so und mache noch einmal etwas dran.
Ich nasche selbst nichts beim Backen.
Dann ist immer schwierig.
Ich will ja nicht verschwenderisch sein,
also kratze ich bis zum letzten Stück aus.
Guck, dann habt ihr fast nichts mehr darauf
und dann kann es gespült werden.
Okay, jetzt hier mit Hilfe des Tuches aufrollen.
Der Anfang ist ein bisschen knifflig,
vor allem, weil die Rolle außen diese Engelshaare hat.
[Musik]
Jetzt hier so ein bisschen andrücken.
Ich muss sagen, die fühlt sich richtig cool an mit diesem Engelshaar.
Dann kommt die Rolle in den Kühlschrank – ich bin gespannt.
Da das jetzt so fix ging, Josh, machen wir noch Künefe Rolls.
JOSH: Ach, das ist aber schade!
SALLY: Ja.
JOSH: Die müssen  wir dann ja auch essen, oder?
SALLY: Ja, die müssen wir dann auch essen.
JOSH: Oh nein!
SALLY: Doch. Dann ist das die XXL Künefe Roll.
Jetzt machen wir noch kleine.
JOSH: Okay!
Also verkürzen wir jetzt doch die Wartezeit mit Künefe Rolls.
Dafür nehme ich wieder Engelshaar, Butter, Mozzarella und Ricotta.
Da könnt ihr dann einfach entscheiden,
ob ihr eine Mozzarella- oder Ricotta-Füllung macht.
Da könnt ihr jetzt im Prinzip entscheiden,
ob ihr Mozzarella oder Ricotta lieber als Füllung nehmen möchtet.
Ich nehme probiere jetzt einfach beides aus.
Traditionell mache ich mein Künefe immer mit Mozzarella,
weil der dann auch so schön Fäden zieht.
Aber mit Ricotta stelle ich es mir auch sehr lecker vor.
Ihr stellt jetzt im Prinzip hier auch einen Zuckerguss her,
also diesen Zuckersirup
- so wie vorhin, mache ich kurz nebenher.
Was ich hier jetzt nur anders machen werde –
ich gebe noch ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt dazu,
könnt ihr auch bei der großen Rolle machen.
So, dann habe ich hier jetzt die Teigfäden.
[Musik]
Dann legt ihr euch hier einen Längsstrang und einen Querstrang – so.
Jetzt nehmt ihr entweder Mozzarella oder Ricotta,
einfach so ein Stück abreißen.
Das kommt hier innen hinein.
Mit diesen Querstreifen könnt ihr die Seiten zuklappen,
dass da nichts ausläuft,
und dann das Ganze aufwickeln.
Ich glaube, das wird so dick.
Ich mache es ein bisschen dünner.
[Musik]
Die Butter kann ich jetzt hier schon einmal schön schmelzen
und dann die restlichen Künefe-Stränge aufrollen.
[Musik]
Ich wollte gerade unserem Team erzählen,
warum in den arabischen Ländern und auch in der Türkei
alles in Zuckersirup getränkt wird.
Das hat ja auch geografische Gründe, nämlich:
Die Türkei und die arabischen Länder sind oft sehr heiß.
Viele Sommer-, heiße Tage, heiße Nächte.
Da ist es einfach so,
dass in Zucker die Dinge viel länger konserviert werden können.
Das heißt, das Gebäck, Baklava z. B. oder Tulumba Tatlısı
oder die anderen Spezialitäten, die man kennt,
sind eigentlich fast alle – wirklich ausnahmslos fast alle –
in Zuckersirup getränkt.
Die kann man nämlich dann bei Raumtemperatur lagern
und sie werden nicht schlecht.
Hier in Deutschland oder in den europäischen Ländern sind die
Sommertage eigentlich relativ kurz, zumindest war es bisher immer so
und man hat viel kühlen können.
Das hat wirklich viel mit dem Essverhalten zu tun.
In Asien z. B. ist es auch so,
dass sie früher nicht so viel Holz hatten.
Deswegen haben sie da,
gerade die japanische Küche, die chinesische Küche,
immer viel Schnitzel- und Schnippelarbeit vorher gehabt,
also viel an Vorbereitung, was man hat,
und dann wird alles nur noch ganz schnell und ganz kurz gebraten,
weil eben Holz knapp war.
In Deutschland hatte man ganz viel Holz in Überschuss.
Deswegen gibt es bei den Deutschen viele Schmorgerichte,
wo man eben auf viel Holz und viel Ofenwärme zurückgreifen kann.
Kleiner Background.
Der Josh so: „Boah!“
JOSH: Eine richtige Geschichtsstunde hier.
SALLY: Ja, so eine richtige Geschichtsstunde.
Das hat dann tatsächlich viel mit dem Essverhalten zu tun,
weil bei den Asiaten ist es wirklich so –
viel vorher schneiden, zubereiten, kleinschneiden
und dann nur kurz anbraten,
weil man eben nur eine kurze Feuerstelle hat.
Ja, bei uns ist es deswegen Zuckersirup, weil es konserviert.
Eben, ist halt so.
Also der Sirup ist jetzt fertig. Den werde ich gleich umfüllen,
damit er abkühlen kann.
Hier habe ich meine Röllchen bzw. Rollen
– die sind ziemlich groß geworden.
Ich versuche die einmal kurz...
Nein, ich werde sie nicht eintauchen.
Ich werde sie nicht in Butter tauchen.
Ich werde sie aber mit Butter übergießen.
Es ist so: Baklava, Tulumba Tatlısı
– es ist alles sehr reich an Kalorien.
[Musik]
Ich glaube, das war zu wenig Butter. [Lacht]
Aber man isst ja jetzt auch nicht 3 dieser Rollen.
Ich muss sagen, ein Rührteig hat auch 250 g Butter.
In einem Marmorkuchen ist auch 250 g Butter.
Also so kalorienarm sind die deutschen Rezepte dann auch wieder nicht.
JOSH: Ich finde es schön, wie du immer etwas gesund redest,
wenn du den Rührteig vergleichst.
[Beide lachen]
Alles, was mehr Punkte hat, ist okay.
SALLY: Ja.
Ah ja, so eine Schwarzwälder-Kirschtorte ist auch Sahne, Zucker...
JOSH: Da hat niemand behauptet, dass sie gesund ist.
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Okay, alles an Süßspeisen ist tendenziell ungesund,
muss man sagen - man darf nicht so viel davon essen.
Habe ich Murat auch gesagt, aber er hat sich nicht darangehalten.
[Musik]
Also ich muss sagen, es war aufwendiger als gedacht.
Ich dachte eigentlich, ich mache das kurz nebenher, aber gut.
Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt würde ich sagen:
Macht die Rolle nicht nach,
macht einfach Künefe ganz traditionell in der Pfanne.
Aber wer weiß, vielleicht schmecken sie ja doch besser als gedacht.
Die werden jetzt im heißen Ofen gebacken.
Der Zuckersirup sollte gleich ganz kalt sein.
Dann werden sie heiß
– das Gebäck ist dann heiß und der Zuckersirup ist kalt.
Nach dem Backen werden sie dann übergossen.
Ich bin gespannt.
[Musik]
Die Biskuit-Rolle ist jetzt abgekühlt.
Die Künefe Rolls sind noch im Backofen.
Sie sind ein bisschen auseinandergelaufen.
Also ich würde sagen, macht das normale Künefe-Rezept in einer Pfanne.
So gehört es sich. Egal!
Die Biskuit-Rolle bekommt jetzt von mir noch
diese Limettenscheiben darauf – als Dekoration.
SARAH: Man hört es brutzeln.
SALLY: Ja, man hört es brutzeln.
Komm, ich hole kurz meine zwei Hobby-Türken mit ins Bild.
SARAH: Künefe Rolls!
SALLY: Bald eigentlich nicht mehr Hobby-Türken,
weil eigentlich könnt ihr mittlerweile schon viel Türkisch, richtig?
SARAH: Ja, wir konvertieren.
[Alle lachen]
SALLY: Dann musst du jetzt fasten, Sarah.
SARAH: Was muss ich?
SALLY: Dann musst du jetzt fasten – mit fasten
JOSH: Kann man das auch auslassen?
SALLY: 30 Tage.
SARAH: Kann man... Okay.
SALLY: Die Rolle ist jetzt fertig.
SARAH: Wie wäre dein türkischer Name?
Wie wären unsere türkischen Namen?
JOSH: Yusuf, oder?
SALLY: Josh wäre Yusuf und Sarah ist Zara.
SARAH: Ah, gibt’s das?
JOSH: Ist aber langweilig.
SALLY: Ja.
SARAH: Wir das mit Z dann...?
SALLY: Ja. Oder...
Also Zara oder wir nennen dich Zeliha.
Das ist die türkische Version von Saliha.
JOSH: Dann seid ihr euch ja noch ähnlicher.
[Sally lacht]
SARAH: Dann sind wir Hanni und Nanni in Türkisch.
SALLY: Ja. Also es ist leider wirklich...
[Alle lachen]
Saliha und Zeliha – oh man!
SARAH: Wo ist Kaymak?
SALLY: Ja, Kaymak! Kannst gucken, ob wir es da haben.
JOSH: Jetzt eskaliert es.
SALLY: Wie gesagt, eigentlich... Irgendwie schon cool.
JOSH: Also ich finde es gut.
SALLY: Ja, oder?
JOSH: Ja.
SARAH: Ich kann kein Kaymak finden.
SALLY: Wartet, dann gebe ich euch eins, was nicht so schön aussieht.
[Beide lachen]
Vielleicht machen wir doch ein Bild.
JOSH: Ich halte ein bisschen fest.
SALLY: Mal gucken. Okay.
JOSH: Komm, okay, das ist so ein bisschen auseinandergefallen.
SALLY: Das ist sehr auseinander gelaufen.
Aber die, die nicht gelaufen sind, finde ich eigentlich recht schön.
Aber es ist zu schwierig, also ich finde es zu aufwendig...
SARAH: Kaymak!
SALLY: Ja, wir waren doch letztes Jahr in der Türkei,
bei unserer Olivenölproduktion.
Die zwei haben sich in Kaymak verliebt.
Kaymak ist so ein Rahm, und den gibt es auch hier.
SARAH: Ist so ein Mensch.
[Alle lachen]
Wir haben uns beide in Kaymak verliebt.
Zum traditionellen türkischen Frühstück gibt es Bal Kaymak,
also Honig mit Kaymak.
Deswegen sind die Zwei verrückt danach.
SARAH: Hat er nicht gesagt!
SALLY: Was hat er gesagt?
JOSH: Nix!
SARAH: Er hat nichts gesagt, aber...
SALLY: So, jetzt probiert einmal so.
SARAH: Ohne Kaymak?
[Josh und Sarah lachen]
JOSH: Bist du wahnsinnig?
SALLY: Ui, aber es ist schon wie bei Künefe...
JOSH UND SARAH: Oh!
SALLY: ... der Käse drin.
JOSH: Original war das doch flach in so einer Pfanne, oder?
SALLY: Genau, entweder macht man eine große Pfanne
für die ganze Familie oder man macht kleine einzelne Pfännchen.
JOSH: Große Pfanne für sich allein gibt es auch.
SARAH: Hier Josh, nimm!
JOSH: Okay. Wo ist Kaymak?
SARAH: Noch nicht anwesend.
[Josh und Sarah lachen]
JOSH: Kaymak kommt später.
[Alle lachen]
SARAH: Kaymak – Okey, es war viel.
SALLY: Oh, das ist lecker!
Es ist schon...
SARAH UND JOSH: Mmh!
SALLY: Sehr lecker, aber heiß!
[Alle lachen]
JOSH: Ein bisschen heiß ist es, aber geht. Mmh!
ALLE: Mmh!
SALLY UND SARAH: Oh!
[Alle lachen]
SARAH: Wir haben überall Engelshaar hängen.
JOSH: Dann sagt der Kaymak: „Hey, mit wem hast du dich getroffen?
Du hast überall Engelshaar?“
[Alle lachen]
Blöd!
SALLY: Oh man, ist das lecker!
Wisst ihr auch, warum das so lecker ist?
Weil da so viel gute Butter drauf ist.
JOSH: Wie hast du das geschnitten?
SARAH: Mit der Gabel.
SALLY: Okay, ich würde sagen:
Künefe Rolls war eher so ein Fail.
Macht lieber das ganz normale Künefe nach.
SARAH: Also ich finde es Hammer!
SALLY: Ja, es ist Hammer lecker, aber ich finde,
dann mach lieber ein Blech.
Das erspart dir viel Arbeit. Deswegen!
SARAH: Das stimmt.
SALLY: Jetzt probieren wir gleich die große Rolle,
weil das muss man schon warm essen.
SARAH: Da bin ich direkt von der Rolle.
SALLY: Das muss man warm essen.
Ihr mit euren Wortspielen.
Das muss man warm essen und das isst man kalt.
SARAH: Die übertreibt ihre Rolle.
[Tusch]
SALLY: Ja, du übertreibst es auch richtig.
[Sarah lacht]
JOSH: Ich sage nichts.
SALLY: Palette!
SARAH: Fällt dir nicht auch ein Wortspiel ein?
JOSH: Nein, ich überlege gerade die ganze Zeit.
SARAH: Ich merke es. Es rattert [Josh stimmt zu]
JOSH: Oh, Kaymak ist da.
SARAH: Kaymak ist angekommen.
Nimm.
JOSH: Danke.
Oh, hier ist das Ergebnis. Mmh!
SALLY: Ist schon sehr lecker.
SARAH: Das ist aber eine Sauerei, muss ich mal ganz ehrlich sagen.
SALLY: Ja, und deswegen ist Künefe einfacher.
SARAH: Ja, das stimmt.
SALLY: Manche Dinge sollte man traditionell lassen.
Okay, wir sehen uns gleich beim Verkosten der Biskuit-Rolle.
[Sarah lacht]
Na los bitte! Kaymak hat schon genug Überstunden! [Josh stimmt zu]
Jutta, du musst das probieren.
SARAH: Boah!
SALLY: Heute darf Dennis probieren.
Du bist ja auch so ein kleiner Hobby-Türke bei uns, muss man sagen
DENNIS: İyiyim. (Mir geht es gut)
SALLY: Nasilsin? (Wie geht’s dir?)
DENNIS: Iyiyim, sen nasilsin? (Gut, und dir?)
SALLY: Bende iyiyim. (Mir geht’s auch gut)
[Beide lachen]
Der Papa ist immer ganz stolz.
DENNIS: Irgendwann werde ich auch noch türkisch...
SALLY: Ja.
DENNIS: ... sprechen.
SALLY: Ja. Hier bitte schön!
DENNIS: Okay, was ist das jetzt genau?
SALLY: Das ist praktisch von den kleinen Künefe Rolls inspiriert.
Von Künefe inspiriert eine große Biskuit-Rolle.
Die kleinen Rollen habe ich dann noch einmal davon inspiriert gemacht.
Hast du einmal Künefe gegessen? Nein, oder?
DENNIS: Die?
SALLY: Die jetzt gerade eben?
DENNIS: Ja, aber...
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Ich wollte nicht verraten,
dass du vor dem Dessert noch ein Dessert hattest.
[Beide lachen]
Aber hast du einmal die Künefe im... nein, oder?
DENNIS: Nein. Das Ding ist,
ich sehe es immer bei türkischen Bäckereien
und denke mir immer: „Boah, das kann doch nicht schmecken!“,
weil das so süß aussieht, und so verklebt und...
Das sieht so aus. [Sally stimmt zu]
Und jetzt habe ich es probiert: Das ist der Hammer! [Sally stimmt zu]
Ich werde jetzt nie wieder daran vorbeilaufen und es nicht essen.
SALLY: Ja. Vielleicht doch, weil dann kannst du es hier essen.
DENNIS: Ich habe mir eigentlich vorgenommen,
bei deinem nächsten Video, in dem ich bin,
wo ich etwas probiere, mal zu sagen, es schmeckt nicht.
SALLY: Und?
DENNIS: Es schmeckt!
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Hauptsache mich dissen wollen!
Ist gut? Ist schwer oder schmeckt es leicht?
DENNIS: Leicht zitronig, weil Limette ist auf jeden Fall...
SALLY: Limette! Wie findest du es mit dem Engelhaar außen herum?
DENNIS: Süß, lecker!
SALLY: Ah, sehr schön.
DENNIS: Lecker!
SALLY: Ah, und Kardamom habe ich drin, im Teig.
DENNIS: Ist das auch Kokos drin?
SALLY: Nein, aber vielleicht ist es Kardamom, was du herausschmeckst,
so ein leichtes Aroma. Ja.
Sehr gut, das freut mich!
DENNIS: Kalorien? Viel, oder?
SALLY: Zu vernachlässigen.
DENNIS: Man sieht es. [Sally stimmt zu]
Aber sehr gut!
SALLY: Hat aber weniger Kalorien als das hier.
DENNIS: Aber die sind auch richtig gut.
SALLY: Aber die sind richtig gut.
Mit der Butter da drin ist schon lecker!
Also probiert das Rezept gerne einmal aus!
Ich finde, es ist ein schönes, leichtes, sommerliches Dessert.
Ob ihr das jetzt mit Kardamom, mit Limette macht,
oder zur Erdbeerzeit auch Erdbeeren in die Mitte packt,
bleibt euch überlassen.
Ich wollte eigentlich Erdbeeren hineinstellen,
aber wir haben noch keine Erdbeerzeit. [Dennis stimmt zu]
Daher noch nicht!
Ich nehme nämlich immer saisonale Erdbeeren vom Bauer Klaus.
Ja, vom Erdbeerfeld direkt hier in Reilingen.
Daher viel Spaß beim Nachbacken,
noch einen schönen Ramadan und bis bald.
DENNIS: Tschüss.
Jetzt kannst du sagen: „Hayırlı Ramazanlar!“ (Gesegneten Ramadan)
DENNIS: Oh, ich verspreche mich!
SALLY: Hayırlı
DENNIS: Hayırlı
SALLY: Ramazanlar
DENNIS: Ramazanlar.
SALLY: Aferin.
DENNIS: Macht’s gut. Tschüss.
Gibt’s in der App.
SALLY: Ja, in der App, genau.
DENNIS: Tschüss.
SALLY: Und jeden Donnerstag ein neuer Podcast.
[Musik]